all right gonna mention right out the
gate this video is brought to you by ray
khan gonna talk about that a little
later but first the boys season three
we're gonna talk about the boys season
three one week after the boys season
three finale aired leave the audience
wanting anything at all that's that's my
mantra it's my code but i thought the
boys season three was great it's the
season we're talking about also gonna
give you a spoiler warning it's not
gonna be a play-by-play i know i say
that in my spoiler videos but this more
so than the spoiler videos like there's
gonna be a lot in this season i don't
talk about because these are my general
thoughts on season three not gonna get
too specific all the time but there are
some things in the finale i felt are
worth talking about you can't talk about
the finale and not give a spoiler
warning it's just
it's common courtesy right so in general
the boys it's just great television the
boys season three and obi-wan were
airing
the round parallel to each other and i
was like i gotta pick one i just felt
like i couldn't do
videos on episodes each episode each
week on two shows just felt like a bit
much i don't know why i probably would
have been fine if i did i just felt like
i had to pick one so i chose obi-wan it
was around halfway through i felt the
whisper
of the of the night from the last
crusade in my ear you have chosen poorly
yeah well maybe i did but the boys is
just one of those shows when it's on
every week i just wait for that next
episode so the general gist of the boys
season three in a world with the boys
always has branching storylines and side
story lines if i could concisely focus
it up the boys free this old soldier
this old hero of yesteryear named
soldier boy played by jensen ackles
they're like we need your help to kill
homelander and he's like great i'll help
you as long as you help me track down my
old crew who betrayed me i want some
revenge of my own they're like deal also
there's this new compound bee called
temp v and it doesn't make you a
superhero forever just gives you powers
for a day and i thought both of these
introductions to the show for this
season temp v and soulja boy i thought
they were excellent first of all jensen
ackles as soldier boy who was incredible
soldier boy is to captain america what
homelander is to superman you know he's
that parallel he's just this gruff
militant rough around the edges [ __ ]
who's just a scene stealer soldier boy i
think we should do this i think you
should choke on my ballsack jensen
ackles was great i haven't seen him in a
role like this before so i'm just like i
i can't believe he's so good at this
also the soldier boy quest to find his
old team and take him out there was
something about this old soldier hunting
down his old team who have superpowers
and he's taking him out some very metal
gear about it i mean it's not verbatim
it's not the plot of metal gear but
there was some sort of connective tissue
with metal gear that i just i just
enjoyed watching him quest to take out
his old crew i mean granted the dudes as
morally compromised as the rest of the
morally compromised superpowered people
in the show but that's the point of the
show very enemy of my enemy if it's not
enemy of my enemy it's very
how to phrase it aim the cannon in the
right direction and hope you take out
the other cannon sometimes you need kano
to take out shao khan it's as simple as
that actually very much reminds me of
mortal kombat the show understands that
people like seeing
entertaining villains also the temp v
arc so butcher and huey both take temp v
and they get super powers butcher has
eye lasers and he's super strong he we
can teleport that we teleport his
clothes are left behind so he just
teleports naked every time the reason i
like that is because it gives insight
you know it's easy to see
how these superheroes are [ __ ] and
they're scumbags but it's another thing
to be able to get those powers and feel
the intoxicating nature of those powers
and be like oh
now i completely understand why they're
that way it gives the characters butcher
especially an insight into his enemy
that he just wouldn't have otherwise i
appreciate that about the show also
leads to some tension between him and
the boys it was a plot device that could
have been just like the cliche okay now
the good guys get super powers now but
they did it in a way that served the
characters i appreciate that about this
season but the scene stealer three
seasons running anthony starr as
homelander the dude is just incredible
he's a rarity you know he's like one of
those actors who portrays a character in
such a way where it's like when he comes
on screen you're like oh okay it's on is
it gonna do shitty things yep am i gonna
be glued to the screen the entire time
absolutely these are guarantees i can
make you an anthony star crushes it once
again i looked into it he's never been
nominated for an emmy for this show
how in a world where you feel like okay
i kind of know what homelander is this
season just ramps it up homelander is
one bad day away from taking us all back
to the stone age he's one mean tweet
away from all of us suffering the
consequences of it he even has his
dialogue in here where he's like i like
being loved but i forgot how he phrased
it he's pretty much like but i'll take
ruling the sender that'll be fine so all
the blackmail they had on the guy you
know the cellphone video and the plane's
pretty much like yeah release it
what do i care i love the fact that
there was this realization where it's
like that threat only has as much power
as i give it and i'm pretty much a god
on earth what do i care about my image
really i mean people
love being loved that's the thing that
homelander
is a human being still he's not an alien
from another planet who's pretty much
like earth is mine to own it's fine i
genuinely don't care about my social
media image he's been wired to care
about it so he does still care about it
but for that moment that logic hit him
or it's just like but what do i really
care about it if it really comes down to
it and i won't lie it was [ __ ]
frightening when that realization hit
homelander the characters in the show me
all of us you have nightmares that night
you'd be forgiven if you did and the
show really shows the power struggles
not even a power struggle a power
struggle denotes that oh this happens
there's no back and forth he just
establishes his power over other
characters like when he made the deep
eat timothy it's a little octopus friend
of the deeps and he's like [ __ ]
timothy and the deep has to eat this
octopus and it was
i don't think i felt that uncomfortable
in a show
ever there's something about how the
show illustrates how the deep sees
sea creatures as people it's just that
knowledge of he has to eat his friend
alive
in one big bite i was horrified i think
that might have been the moment where i
was like season three is pretty epic
because it's just it's getting that kind
of reaction out of me as someone who can
watch requiem for a dream every friday
night and feel fine saturday morning
that timothy scene it kind of [ __ ] me
up yeah i've seen guys shrink and go
into people's dick holes and then
accidentally enlarge and blow that
person in half but that's the scene
where i'm like hey a friend's over you
got to see the scene the timothy scene
i'm like
do you want to watch it it will change
you i will say this is probably the most
sexually explicit season you know
shockingly so it does so for shock
factor for sure but it does so very
effectively because it also it's like
there's this whole hero-gasm episode
where it's it's just superhero orgies
everywhere but then you're met with oh
soldier boys coming and all these people
might very well die so it's the tension
is still there it's not just for the
sake of hirogasm this is the season
where it's like frenchy in kamiko it's
like the show is genuinely
what do we do with them so their arc is
a very personal one that feels more
detached than the vision as a whole for
the season season three of the show but
i can't deny that i just i like the
characters you know and i do like seeing
them in the show and i don't want the
show to write them off entirely or
anything so noir is dead he knew about
soldier boy being homelander's father
and homelander just punches him through
his stomach his intestines hanging out i
mean the guy heals sure but sometimes
it's like i don't think he's coming back
from that which i guess going forward i
don't know if you heard this but i guess
they're gonna have another noir i mean
they can keep that up every season noir
can die every season now they can just
have a new guy being noir but there was
an intriguing element to noir you know
like noir going forward i'm gonna be
like yeah but
can you play the piano like that was one
of the most intriguing things to me i
think it was the first season noir sits
down just looks at the person at the
piano until they uncomfortably leave and
he starts playing the piano now like
that moment was with that character who
is dead but going forward i'm like yeah
but you're not that guy i started to get
bummed out in season three when they
started doing the whole information dump
on noir's pass i was like oh that's a
lot very fast you're ruining some
intrigue but okay now we know more oh
he's dead so that's why okay
that's why with the info dump and maeve
was one of those characters i felt like
they didn't know what they wanted to do
with maeve so when maeve actually just
kind of rolls her eyes like ah [ __ ] and
she grabs soldier boy when soldier boy
is about to do the explosion thing and
they jump out the window and the
explosion happens i was like oh maeve
went out like a hero i thought that was
awesome oh look at that maeve's alive
it's like another show that's afraid to
commit to the deaths of the characters
even when the character's death would
have been a great death and the best way
to send them out of the show if you
haven't seen heroes
earmuffs spoiler alert but i hated that
nathan petrelli lived through that
because that was supposed to be his
moment where he's like i learned to be a
hero you save the cheerleader so we can
save the world he grabs peter and they
fly up boom explosion oh he's alive for
season two i just hate it when heroic
moments get undone because like well we
can't kill them but in the end i thought
the boys season three was great season
one's tops because nothing beats that
first experience seeing this
new take on superheroes and realizing
that this is probably the more accurate
version of them but it's 1-3-2 for me
the tension was ripe the characters both
old and new i thought were great and in
the end the boys remains one of the most
clever and entertaining shows that's
currently on right now and as mentioned
before this video is brought to you by
raycon earbuds raycon earbuds are those
slick stylish true wireless earbuds that
come in about half the price of the
competition and still crank out that
sound they have optimized gel tips for a
snug fit they're not gonna fall out of
your head and holding in the button on
the left earbud for three seconds allows
you to cycle through the different sound
options here sound balance sound and
bass sound once i learned that that took
these earbuds from my workout earbuds to
my workout earbuds plus using the power
of music to pass the time while doing
any menial task earbuds and if you
prefer to charge cable free raycon
earbuds have wireless charging
capability props for convenience so
click the link below or go to
buyreicon.com to get yourself 15 off
your purchases the world's always better
with the power of music right so the
boys season three have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you